the Joe Rogan experience hopefully I get
any Bravo on the day Oh a cheeto very
yeah you get him on ya Cheetos fight is
canceled right I know so they trying to
give him a replacement opponent I was
hoping they'd shut out the cheeto Vera
yeah he loved your show bot I loved him
he too tough [ __ ] he is he it
was not love sugar Shawn Allah I love
how you taking it - yeah he'd taken it
because you know I've seen a lot of
people online talking about you know
already gonna move the car to enter home
now I'm doing that for sugar Shawn no no
he got a he got a tainted supplement
yeah it's it's these new studies are
these new tests that they have they are
so [ __ ] extensive they catch [ __ ]
that you did years ago that's crazy and
if you took a tainted supplement which
something that has zero performance
benefit years ago it can still show up
in your system whereas they used to have
like Oh it'll be out of your system in
six weeks like especially talked like a
gem professor like there's a lot look
there's a lot of cheating in
professional sports there's always it
cheating for sure a lot of cheating and
mmm a lot but less than they used to be
because of you sada and Nowitzki and
what the UFC is implemented 100% less
but supplements are a dirty business I
know this firsthand from on it from
being one of the owners of on it yeah
and not even supplements tainted with
things that are illegal when we first
started making alpha brain we had it
independently tested we get all our [ __ ]
third-party tested yeah and we were like
what the [ __ ] is this doing in there we
had stuff in there that's not supposed
to be in there well it turns out when
you get stuff made like say if you have
a you put together some sort of a
pre-workout drink and you want to have
vitamin b12 and all these different
things in it you get those mixed by a
third party lab this lab mixes it all
for you but you don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing I don't know what they do
vac yeah they're not cleaning out their
[ __ ] so they might have been doing
steroids right before they do your [ __ ]
and you're having to make mix you have
some creatine and your creatine has aa
strain in it which is like you know what
is it some kind of steroid I don't know
what it is it's some kind of steroid I
was talking about a bodybuilder Micra
she'd about supplements cuz you know
obviously he a bodybuilder yeah
he has a company I think he he works
with trifecta - or something like that
and I was just like how do how does that
happen like these tainted supplements
and I interviewed him about I'm gonna
release it one day how he goes into it
but you know what bodybuilders they
catch flack because they bodybuilders
you got to be on something but these
guys know they [ __ ] he has a legitimate
business so I'm sure he does but most of
them are on something like if you want
to get to the size of like a Lee Haney
you don't get that big without steroids
it's not a human size you know when you
get to like you know you just go back
and look at like Franco Columbu favorite
oh my god but but then you look at like
Frank Zane Frank Zane you can get that
body without steroids what about
possible
what about Francis Francis in Ghana he
started to be a bodybuilder oh yeah a
gigantic yeah there's naturally there's
natural Kamal's maan is a freak yeah
like in woodleigh's if you date freaks
rock Lesnar's a freak
there's freaks
[Applause]